we will now discuss the Morgan's laws
that are some very useful relations
between sets and their complements one
of the Morgan's laws takes this form if
we take the intersection of two sets and
then take the complement of this
intersection what we obtain is the union
of the complements of the two sets
pictorially here is the situation we
have our Universal set inside that set
we have a set s which is this one and we
have another set T which is this one let
us look at this side the complement of s
is this part of the diagram the
complement of T is this part of the
diagram what is left what is left is
just this region here which is the
intersection of s with T so anything
that does not belong here belongs to the
intersection that this means that the
complement of the intersection is
everything out there which is this set
if you are not convinced by this
pictorial proof let us go through an
argument that is a little more formal
what does it take for an element to
belong to the first set in order to
belong to that set X belongs to the
complement of s intersection T this is
the same as saying that X does not
belong to the intersection with s with T
what does that mean since it is not in
the intersection this is the same as
saying that X does not belong to s or X
does not belong to T but this is the
same as saying that X belongs to the
complement of s or X belongs to the
complement of T
and this is equivalent to saying that X
belongs to the union of the complement
of s with the complement of T so this
establishes this first the Morgans
law there's another de Morgan's law
which is obtained from this one by a
syntactic substitution we're going to
play the following trick wherever we see
an S we're going to replace it by s
complement and wherever we see an s
complement we will replace it with an S
and similarly whenever we see a T we'll
replace it by T complement and when we
see a T complement we will replace it by
T so doing this synthetic substitution
what we obtain is s complement
intersection with T complement
everything gets complemented is the same
as s Union T now let us take compliments
of both sides the complement of a
complement is the set itself so we
obtain this and now we take the
complement of the other side which is
this one and this is the second de
Morgan's law it tells us that the
complement of a union is the same as the
intersection of the complements we
derived it from the first de Morgan's
law by a syntactic substitution if you
are not convinced it would be useful for
you to go through an argument of this
kind to show that something is an
element of this set if and only if it is
an element of that set as well finally
it turns out that the Morgan's laws are
valid when we take unions or
intersections of more than two sets
there is a more general form and the
general form is as follows in analogy
with this one if we have a collection of
sets s n perhaps an infinite collection
we take the intersection of those sets
and then the complement what that is is
the union of the complement
so this is analogous to this law and
this law extends to this one if we have
the union of certain sets and we take
the compliment of the Union what we
obtain is the intersection of the
complements we will have many occasions
to use de Morgan's laws they're actually
very useful they allow us in general to
go back and forth between unions and
intersections